jeter de l'huile sur le feu c'est le
reproche fait aux agents fédéraux
déployés à portland dans le nord ouest
des états unis
ces policiers sont notamment accusés de
procéder à des arrestations de
manifestants sans leur fournir de motif
des arrestations parfois comparé à des
enlèvements envoyés sur place pour
mettre fin à une hausse des violences
dans un contexte de manifestations
contre les brutalités policières
leur départ a même été demandé par
l'édile de portland alors à new york où
donald trump menace de les déployer
le maire tente de faire barrage cela ne
nous apportera pas plus de sécurité nous
prendrions immédiatement des mesures
devant la justice pour l'arrêter tout
serait un autre exemple d'action
illégale et inconstitutionnelle prise
par le président new york n'est pas la
seule ville démocrates menacés par
l'envoi des forces fédérales
les maires de seattle chicago atlanta ou
encore la capitale fédérale washington
ont envoyé une lettre au ministre de la
justice un document dans lequel ils
censurent jeu contre le déploiement
unilatérale de ces forces de police
décrié la maison blanche à elle réagi en
défendant l'utilisation de ces agents le
président trump ne laissera pas passer
la violence il rétablira l'ordre là où
le gouverneur démocrate et le maire
démocrates ne veulent pas admettre
qu'ils ont perdu le contrôle de leur
ville
l'administration trump exhorte les
autorités nationales et locales à
travailler en coopération pour rétablir
la loi et l'ordre
le retour de la loi et l'ordre nouvelle
stratégie de campagne de donald trump
critiqué pour sa gestion de la pandémie
due coronavirus dans les derniers
sondages à trois mois et demi de la
présidentielle il se retrouve devancé
par son rival démocrate joe biden